all right next up hot off the presses
we've got two copies right here two
copies of the hottest new newspaper it's
called the owensboro kids chronicle and
yahoo life reports this little
independent paper out of kentucky comes
from the brain of an 11 year old
editor-in-chief her name is audrey neal
and she loves writing so much that she
started her very own newspaper with
sections on everything from nature to
sports and you know what she's up to 30
subscribers across the country
make it 32
because we have a copy right here
come on what would you be writing about
as an 11 year old well i did right a lot
yeah 11 year old it's called little girl
lost yeah
this young woman
has just captured my heart and i am
going to become a subscriber thank you
for putting this out yes thank you
and can i just
i just
i just want to thank you for putting a
word search in here as opposed to a
crossword puzzle because crossword
puzzles are too tough for me but i can
always find
look there's horse
thank you
thank you also i'm going to subscribe um
not only for myself but i'm going to get
two more subscriptions one for olive and
one for frankie michael i love that
you're up to 34. yeah
and you know what if you go to the
drewberrymart show.com on our website
you can find a way to subscribe to this
most meaningful beautiful newspaper may
we encourage her support her and get
more people to do something like this
this is
and amazing is a pick from drew's little
yellow book and that's our list
that i personally carry
that is very meaningful and important to
me because i love sharing today's pick
is a chocolate company that i cannot
live without it's oh my god
look
look we're on it you see this it says
news on it
oh look this
[Applause]
i just can't believe that tony's
chocolate who i was this is choco lonely
and um they've embellished it in drew's
news wrapping and it just it means so
much to me so thank you tony's you're
one of my favorite chocolate companies
on the planet i was just promoting you
because i love you i had no idea that i
would be involved in this but more
importantly everybody is getting a
hundred dollar gift card for tony's
chocolate
[Applause]
if you go to their website
you get to make your own custom wrappers
that is so cute
thank you tony
[Music]
you